[Musique]
bienvenue dans leurs dépôts ravi d'être
là à la place de pascal praud chers amis
téléspectateurs j'ai l'honneur de vous
dire qu'elle a pris minibus est
actuellement en route pour colombey les
deux églises évidemment il va se rendre
à touba pèlerinage en l'honneur de
charles de gaulle pascal est parti dans
amenons et pascal et la formidable les
bonnets écharpes pascal je voulais voir
ce que ça faisait de chausser ses
lunettes si célèbre françaises français
mes chers compatriotes de métropole
d'outre-mer et de l'étranger
je tenais en cet automne 2021 à revenir
vers vous pour répondre aux
interrogations
parfois aux inquiétudes qui sont les
vôtres sur notre situation sanitaire ça
va bien se passer on n'a jamais eu
d'accident
ne laissez pas votre mal de gorge
prendre la parole pour ceux qui suivent
assez tabou depuis 20 heures le
président était envolé ce soir à bruges
à fond dans la gorge il avait un grand
château marie ménagerie entière
très gros chat dans la gorge beaucoup
ont embarqué sur les réseaux sociaux que
le président a changé de vaud ça y est
il a mué
les mesures annoncées ce soir notamment
concernent notamment le renforcement des
contrôles de pacini terre et le port du
voile et elles vont avoir et le port du
masque pardonnez-moi benetton créé la
polémique voir le scandale la marque de
vêtements lance un voile islamique pour
hommes et pour femmes un chan a oui une
association avec le rappeur d'origine
tunisienne ghalia alors l'idée divise si
certains saluent l'idée ou sont amusé
d'autres y voient une banalisation du
voile islamique en plein désert
d'atacama des vêtements à perte de vue
des chaussures ou même des après-ski ici
au nord du chili les piles dhabi
s'amoncellent le pays s'est spécialisée
dans le commerce de vêtements de seconde
main et se retrouve aujourd'hui débordé
des habits venus du monde entier qui ne
sont pas toujours revendu et se retrouve
dans ces décharges sauvages
mais qui permettent à ces migrants de se
vêtir à l' approche de l'hiver elle en
dirait quoi geneviève
[Musique]
les temps ont bien changé
en l'embrassant elle est plus là
maintenant on monte nos brillants toi
d'ici là je les cache et là je pense
qu'il est bien dissimulé
et puis le foulard ou 5 mais avant
d'atteindre mon sac de la distance donc
je me mette dans le seul bar normal je
n'ai pas le choix je suis content
débardeur pour cacher parce que nous
souhaitons aussi par c'est pas très
discret ça ne fait un gros paquet mais
bon ils sont de retour sur terre après
plus de six mois de mission thomas
pesquet a quitté la capsule après un
long voyage il a commencé hier après
midi
quatre des sept astronautes de la
mission crew deux rejoignent la capsule
le moment des derniers nettoyage pour
thomas pesquet
le sas relions la capsule l iss se ferme
il est 20 heures 5 lorsque les deux
parties se séparent extraits un par un
et placés sur des brancards par
précaution difficile pour eux de se
tenir debout après leur épopée spatiale
les quatre astronautes ont amerri en
pleine nuit au large de la floride après
un trajet de plus de huit heures
thomas pesquet donc de retour sur scène
sur scène sur terre et il sera dès ce
soir à cologne c'est là que se trouve le
centre européen des astronautes il va y
rester trois semaines pour se réadapter
à la vie sur terre donc on va pas tout
de suite le voir en france pas tout de
suite si ce n'est attendre encore un peu
trash et triste
non pardon si vous aussi vous rêvez
d'aller faire un tour dans l'espace
sachez que 100 tickets ont déjà été
vendus pour un premier vol commercial
qui est prévue fin 2022 c'est notre
chiffre du jour alors il faut avoir un
peu d'argent parce que la valeur d'un
billet pour voir la terre de tout en
haut ces quatre cent cinquante mille
dollars à d'abord ça fait rêver de
partir dans les étoiles ça fait rêver
d'y envoyer quelqu'un ça fait rêver tous
fait rêver dans cette histoire les
lorsqu'on avait envoyé un robot sur mars
moi j'étais comme une fois que j'avais
envie de regarder en direct quand il est
arrivé mais cela dit les photos de
thomas pesquet tous les deux jours tout
ça je sais pas j'avoue un moment je me
suis un peu lassé vous avez vécu en
russie jusqu'à quel âge qu'à mes trois
ans
j'obtiens souvenirs je sais dire mais je
suis pas sûr que je dise bien il ya
thelonious je t'aime way attendu pour
être précis parce que y'a tibial oublier
que ça veut dire je t'aime ou bio ça
veut dire j'ai envie de te tuer
alors vous faites bien de le préciser le
véritable yves montand la véritable
grand papa benjamin elle est écrite pas
emmanuel bonini qui n'a rien à voir avec
le restaurant dans lequel on a été chez
nini la dernière fois il revient sur la
vie d'yves montand et sur ses secrets
inavoués parmi ce secret n'y en a un qui
peut avoir de grandes conséquences c'est
celui des enfants cachés des montants
qui sont ils aurait-il droit à
l'héritage il monte en aurait aussi eu
des aventures avec un homme pour se
lancer dans le milieu et peut-être même
un bébé avec marilyn monroe est donc le
premier smap l'est pour me souhaiter un
bon rétablissement parce que j'ai dit
que j'étais malade dans un premier temps
je savais pas comment amener la chose et
puis c'est vrai que si vous dites que
vous fait une fausse couche on va
profiter des choses sur vous vous ira
peut-être ça veut dire que elle va elle
va avoir elle veut avoir un bébé et où
elle veut faire ci ou ça c'est une
fragilité est-ce que c'est mon dessert
une citation au début oui mais eux mais
qu'ils aient un bail n'est pas un
biographe qui qui trempe sa plume dans
la guimauve oui mais voilà
c'est cissé sylla sinon ça va pour elle
écrit ça donc
je vous le dis les grands
suffisant
elle est aussi rapide kabyle dans
l'esquivé
[Musique]
on sait que toi les livres la culture
c'est pas ton temps
j'aurais pu signer son bouquet est l
image de sa de ses mentalités c'est toi
tu veux tu as deux supports je te
réponds je te ménager des arguments
n'est pas tombé dessus et nous avons eu
la confirmation qui à plusieurs reprises
vous avez demandé à des pêcheurs qui
passaient au large de la nourriture et
que plusieurs fois on vous a apporté à
manger
sur le camp
j'ai mangé j'ai mangé de fin ça se passe
aux etats unis ces derniers alors ici
c'est serré et tout ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que guilhem le désert elle aime
aussi beaucoup de poulet
j'ai bien lu m'a fait bondir je vais
arrêter passer du salaire est pas comme
vous pouvez le voir on pourra alors voir
cet épisode c'est très très bien géré et
il a fallu un peu de bazar oui oui on
avait avancé pas lui je le connais à
voir
la loi de koh lanta je les fais quoi je
les fais theora pour vous koh-lanta se
termine aujourd'hui merci en tout cas à
la bombe à jamais à vous et vous irez
vous vous parlez tous les deux je parle
pas lui mais il m'a raccroché au nez
leur donner la dernière conversation
[Applaudissements]
francine c'est ça oui c'est francine est
la numéro d'écrou français l'univers oui
ça m'a changé
toute l'équipe alors toujours à la
farine
écoutez je prends les nouvelles